>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
HAPPY FRIDAY.
IN RETROSPECT, JOE BIDEN'S FIRST
TERM POLICY AGENDA SEEMS VERY
OPTIMISTIC, ALMOST COMICALLY
OPTIMISTIC.
SHORTLY BEFORE HIS INAUGURATION,
HE ANNOUNCED SOMETHING HE CALLED
THE "BUILD BACK BETTER AGENDA."
WE MOCKED IT AT THE TIME, BUT
LOOKING BACK IN SOME WAYS IT WAS
A HOPEFUL DOCUMENT.
AMERICA MUST'VE BEEN A VERY RICH
COUNTRY BACK THEN.
AND BY BACK THEN WE MEAN LAST
YEAR.
THERE WEREN'T A LOT OF
ESSENTIALS IN BIDEN'S AGENDA.
THE FIRST THREE THINGS THAT ANY
NORMAL NATION NEEDS AND THINKS
ABOUT OBSESSIVELY OUR FOOD,
WATER, AND ENERGY.
THAT IS THE STANDARD.
IN CHINA FOR EXAMPLE, EVERY
GOVERNMENT POLICY IS DESIGNED
ABOVE ALL TO PRESERVE ATTIC
ADEQUATE FOOD, WATER, ENERGY
BEER THAT MAKES SENSE.
THE BUILD BACK JUMPED ON MUCH
BETTER AGENDA WAS THE OPPOSITE
OF THAT.
IT DID NOT ADDRESS ANY CONCERN
ON WHETHER AMERICANS MIGHT HAVE
ENOUGH TO EAT OR AFFORD NOT TO
FREEZE TO DEATH.
FOCUSED ON THE KIND OF ADDED
EXTRAS YOU GET TO WHEN YOU FIX
EVERYTHING ELSE AND THEN STILL
HAVE TRILLIONS LEFT OVER.
BUILD BACK BETTER PROMISED SO
SOMETHING CALLED "ENVIRONMENTAL
EQUITY."
IT DEMANDED AMNESTY FOR MILLIONS
OF ILLEGAL ALIENS BECAUSE AT THE
TIME THE AMERICAN ECONOMY SEEMED
ROBUST ENOUGH TO SHARE WITH THE
ENTIRE WORLD.
BIDEN CALLED FOR FREE SOLAR
PANELS FOR EVERYBODY AND
TAXPAYER FUNDED PRE-K FOR ALL
AMERICAN PARENTS AND SO ON AND
SO ON.
IT WAS THE NEOLIBERAL VERSION OF
FLYING CARS, LUXURIES THAT FOR A
MOMENT IN TIME SEEMED ALMOST
WITHIN REACH.
A LOT HAS CHANGED.
NOBODY'S TALKING ABOUT FLYING
CARS ANYMORE.
HERE IS JOE BIDEN FROM
YESTERDAY.
>> WITH REGARD TO FOOD SHORTAGE,
YES, WE DID -- WE WILL TALK
ABOUT FOOD SHORTAGES.
IT IS GOING TO BE REAL.
THE PRICE OF THESE SANCTIONS IS
NOT JUST IMPOSED UPON RUSSIA.
IT IS IMPOSED UPON AN AWFUL LOT
OF COUNTRIES IS WELCOME
INCLUDING EUROPEAN COUNTRIES AND
OUR COUNTRY AS WELL.
BOTH RUSSIA AND UKRAINE HAVE
BEEN THE BREADBASKET OF EUROPE
IN TERMS OF WEIGHT, FOR EXAMPLE,
JUST TO GIVE YOU ONE EXAMPLE.
>> Tucker: FOOD SHORTAGES.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE REAL --
ONCE AGAIN, IN CASE YOU MISSED
IT, FOOD SHORTAGES.
NOT IN SUDAN, AND CINCINNATI.
I WAS IN HER BIG CITIES ALSO SO.
OUR PROBLEM HAS ALWAYS BEEN
HAVING TOO MUCH FOOD, NOW WE
WON'T HAVE ENOUGH.
WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
JUST TOLD US THAT ON CAMERA.
WHAT IS THIS GOING TO MEAN?
HOW DO FOOD SHORTAGES AFFECT A
COUNTRY?
IF YOU ARE TO GO ONLINE AND READ
ABOUT IT, ALL OF RECORDED
HISTORY WILL ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION.
FOOD SHORTAGE IS NOT LIKE
DECIDING TO SKIP DESSERT.
IT IS NOT A DIET, IT IS NOT
VOLUNTARY.
A FOOD SHORTAGE IS DIFFERENT.
IT IS SCARY.
IT DOES TOPPLED GOVERNMENTS AND
TURNING MODERATES INTO
REVOLUTIONARIES.
A FOOD SHORTAGE IS A BIG DEAL,
YOU DON'T WANT ONE.
BUT NOW WE ARE GETTING ONE.
JUST A LITTLE OVER A YEAR INTO
JOE BIDEN'S PRESIDENCY.
THINK FORWARD.
IF THE TRADITIONAL CALENDAR
HOLDS, WE'VE GOT 1,032 DAYS LEFT
OF THE JOE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
AND YOU WONDER WHAT THINGS WILL
LOOK LIKE BY THEN.
WE ARE SPEEDING TOWARDS A
DYSTOPIA.
NOT THAT THEY SEEM TO CARE IN
ANY WAY.
HERE'S TREASURY SECRETARY JANET
ALLEN FROM THIS MORNING TO LET
YOU KNOW IT'S TIME TO STOP
WHINING ABOUT GAS PRICES BECAUSE
ACTUALLY, THEY ARE NOT VERY
HIGH.
>> HOW HIGH DO YOU THINK OIL
GET?
>> LISTEN, THERE'S A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY.
THEY ARE NOT AS HIGH IN REAL
TERMS AS THEY WERE EARLIER IN
THIS CENTURY.
AND, YOU KNOW, IT'S CONCEIVABLE
THAT THEY COULD MOVE HIGHER.
>> Tucker: YEAH, IT'S NOT A
BIG DEAL, SETTLE DOWN HERE THERE
IS A REASON FOR IT.
AS JOE BIDEN EXPLAINED, YOU ARE
PAYING MORE FOR GAS BECAUSE WE
HAVE SLAP SANCTIONS ON RUSSIA.
SANCTIONING RUSH IS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO.
FOR SOME PEOPLE, THIS MIGHT SEEM
LIKE AN ADEQUATE ANSWER, BUT
OTHERS IN GOOD FAITH MAY ASK,
OKAY, I'M NOT AGAINST SANCTIONS
AND THEORY, BUT SINCE THEY ARE
CLEARLY NOT HURTING PUTIN AND
THEY ARE HEARD IN MY FAMILY,
WHAT IS THE POINT OF SANCTIONS?
IS THERE A POINT?
LET ME KNOW, MAKE ME FEEL
BETTER.
THE ANSWER IS YES, THERE IS A
POINT TO SANCTIONS BEAR THEY ARE
DESIGNED TO PREVENT RUSSIA FROM
INVADING UKRAINE.
WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE NOT SO LONG
AGO THE SECRETARY OF STATE TOLD
CNN "THE PURPOSE OF THE SANCTION
IN THE FIRST INSTANCE IS TO TRY
TO DETER RUSSIA FROM GOING TO
WAR."
JEN PSAKI, THE PRESIDENT'S
PUBLICIST, BACKED THEM UP.
"OUR INTENTION TO HAS DON'T LIKE
TO HAVE A DETERMINED THROUGH
SANCTIONS."
THE DETERRENT EFFECT OF THE
ANCIENT DOME EXTENSIONS IS STILL
A MEANINGFUL ONE PAIRED SO THEY
WERE, EXCEPT THEY DIDN'T
ACTUALLY WORK.
PUTIN INVADED UKRAINE ANYWAY.
THE SANCTIONS FAILED.
SO WHAT IS THE RESPONSE?
JOE BIDEN IS PRETENDING THE
ADMINISTRATION NEVER CLAIMED TO
SANCTIONS TO DETER RUSSIA FROM
INVADING UKRAINE.
HERE IS THE NEW LINE.
>> LET'S GET SOMETHING STRAIGHT.
IF YOU COVERED ME FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING, I DID NOT SAY THAT IN
FACT THESE SANCTIONS WOULD DETER
HIM.
SANCTIONS NEVER DETER.
YOU KEEP TALKING ABOUT THAT.
THE MEANNESS OF SANCTIONS, THE
INCREASING PAIN AND
DEMONSTRATION -- WHY ASKED FOR
THIS NATO MEETING TODAY IS TO BE
SURE THAT AFTER A MONTH, WE WILL
SUSTAIN WHAT WE ARE DOING, NOT
JUST NEXT MONTH, THE FOLLOWING
MONTH, BUT FOR THE REMAINDER OF
THIS ENTIRE YEAR.
THAT IS WHAT WILL BEN.
>> WHAT DOES THAT EVEN MEAN?
SANCTIONS NEVER DETER -- WHY DO
YOU KEEP SAYING THAT?
IF YOUR WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY, YOUR SECRETARY OF
STATE, ALL SAID THAT VERBATIM.
BUT THEY ARE NOT TECHNOLOGY NOT
HOPING THAT OUR MEMORIES HAVE
BEEN SO DAMAGED BY THE iPHONE
IT WILL BE AS FORGETFUL AS
JOE BIDEN HIMSELF.
NOW THEY WANT US TO BELIEVE THAT
SANCTIONING RUSSIA CAN FORCE
PUTIN INTO WITHDRAWING FROM
UKRAINE.
IS THAT TRUE?
CAN PUTIN BE SANCTIONED INTO
RETREAT?
WE CERTAINLY HOPE IT IS TRUE,
SINCERELY.
BUT THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT IT
IS TRUE.
IT'S NOT EVEN REALLY AN
EXPECTATION THAT IT IS TRUE.
EVEN JOE BIDEN DIDN'T CLAIM THAT
WAS GOING TO HAPPEN.
SO WHAT IS THE POINT?
WE ARE NOT SURE, THAT IS A TOPIC
FOR ANOTHER SHOW.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME, THIS
COUNTRY, WE KNOW THIS FOR SURE,
IS BEING BADLY HURT BY THOSE
SANCTIONS.
AS RECENTLY REPORTED "WESTERN
SANCTIONS ON RUSSIA, A MAJOR
EXPORTER OF OTHER NUTRIENTS,
HAVE DISRUPTED SHIPMENTS OF
THOSE KEY INPUTS AROUND THE
GLOBE.
FERTILIZER IS KEY TO KEEPING
CORN, SOY, RICE, AND WHEAT
YIELDS HIGH.
THEY ARE SCRAMBLING TO ADJUST.
ARE YOU FOLLOWING THIS?
THOSE INGREDIENTS ARE NECESSARY
TO PUT FOOD ON YOUR TABLE AT A
PRICE YOU CAN AFFORD.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE THOSE
INGREDIENTS, WHAT DO YOU GET?
FOOD SHORTAGES.
WHICH ARE A DIRECT RESULT OF
POLICY FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
A POLICY WHOSE INTENDED EFFECT
IS STILL NOT CLEAR.
WHAT IS THE POINT OF THIS?
IF THERE'S A GOOD POINT, PEOPLE
WILL PUT UP WITH IT.
WHY DON'T YOU TELL US WHAT THAT
POINT IS.
FERTILIZER BILLS ARE EXPECTED TO
JUMP AROUND 50% JUST THIS YEAR
AND THEY COULD GO HIGHER.
THEY SAY THEY ARE ALREADY SEEN
THEM GO MUCH HIGHER.
WATCH.
>> MICHAEL ANDERSON'S FAMILY HAS
BEEN FUNDED WHEAT, SOYBEANS, AND
CORN SINCE THE 1950s.
HE EXPECTS HIM TO THROW A
CURVEBALL, BUT NOT A WAR.
>> ALL OF THE STUFF IN
UKRAINE -- THERE ARE SOME ITS
VOLATILITY IN THE MARKET.
>> THE IMPORT $10.3 BILLION
WORTH OF FERTILIZER FOR CROPS.
1.3 BILLION OF THAT COMES FROM
RUSSIA.
WHICH IS NOW OFF THE MARKET.
THE MINNESOTA ASSOCIATION OF
WHEAT GROWERS SAYS FARMERS LAY
DOWN FERTILIZER AT LEAST TWICE A
YEAR.
>> THERE'S A LOT OF FERTILIZER
THAT ARE MORE EXPENSIVE THAN
THEY WERE A YEAR AGO.
FERTILIZER HAS DRASTICALLY OUT
PAID.
>> IT'S SCHEDULED TO LAST UNTIL
THE END OF THE YEAR.
WHILE SUPPLY IS ALREADY TIGHT
THIS YEAR, IT IS THE FUTURE AND
MANY ARE WORRIED ABOUT.
>> SO SANCTIONS HAVE THROWN
AMERICAN AGRICULTURE INTO
PROFOUND TURMOIL AND WILL
CAUSE -- AGAIN, THE PRESIDENT
HAS TOLD US OUT LOUD, FOOD
SHORTAGES, WHICH ARE MAY BE THE
MOST DESTABILIZING TREND YOU
COULD EVER HAVE IN A COUNTRY.
NOT JUST OF THE POLITICS, BUT TO
THE SOCIAL FABRIC.
IT'S NOT JUST THE WAR IN
UKRAINE.
IN RESPONSE TO ENERGY AND FOOD
SHORTAGES, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS SHUTTING DOWN
DOMESTIC OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION.
THAT MAKES FOOD MORE EXPENSIVE
AND EVERYTHING ELSE MORE
EXPENSIVE.
AS THE PRESSURE ON AMERICAN
FARMERS RISES AND AS FOOD BECOME
SCARCER AND MORE EXPENSIVE IN
THIS COUNTRY, THAT SAME
ADMINISTRATION IS ALLOWING THE
GOVERNMENT OF CHINA TO BUY UP
THIS COUNTRY'S FARM OIL.
ACCORDING TO POLITICO, AND THIS
WAS TWO YEARS AGO, CHINESE
INVESTORS OWNED NEARLY
200,000 ACRES OF U.S. AT
BATMAN'S VALUED AT LEAST
2 BILLION.
NOW THEY ARE DOING THIS IN THE
HELP WITH SUBSIDIES -- THEY ARE
CONTINUING TO BUY MORE EVERY
SINGLE YEAR.
AGAIN, FOOD, WATER, ENERGY.
THAT IS WHAT YOU NEED FOR A
COUNTRY.
THE CHINESE UNDERSTAND THAT.
CONGRESSMAN SAID, THE CURRENT
TREND OF THE UNITED STATES IS
LEADING US TOWARDS THE CREATION
OF THE CHINESE OWNED AGRICULTURE
LAND MONOPOLY.
IN OUR COUNTRY.
THE MOST PRODUCTIVE FARMLAND IN
THE WORLD.
NOW OWNED BY WHAT WE USED TO
CALL OUR MAIN GLOBAL RIVAL AND
NOW WE CAN SAY WITH THE
REALIGNMENT IN PROGRESS IS THE
MAIN ENEMY FUNDED BY A COUNTRY
THAT SEEKS TO DISPLACE US AND
PUNISH US.
IT'S INSANE.
WITH THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT
PERMIT AMERICAN INVESTORS TO BUY
ITS COUNTRY'S FARM LAND OR WATER
RESOURCES?
IT'S NOT EVEN A REAL QUESTION.
OF COURSE NOT.
NO SAME COUNTRY WOULD DO THAT.
NO FOREIGN ENTITY SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO CONTROL AMERICA'S
CRITICAL NATURAL RESOURCES.
SO HOW LONG UNTIL THEY START
SWEEPING UP THE GREAT LAKES,
WHICH ARE THE LARGEST RIVERS RER
OF FRESH WATER?
AND IT COULD HAPPEN MUCH SOONER
THAN ANYONE SEEMS TO REALIZE.
WATCH.
>> GAS PRICES ARE JACKING UP THE
COST OF BOAT RENTALS AND
CHARTERS.
LEAVING CAPTAINS LIKE CANDY WITH
TWO CHOICES.
CANCEL CHARTERS THAT ARE NOT
PROFITABLE OR INCREASED TICKET
PRICES.
THE INCREASES ARE NOT JUST
HITTING THE TOURISM INDUSTRY.
FROM OUR BOATS THAT GO OUT
FISHING TO OUR TRUCKS THAT
DELIVER THE PRODUCT, EVERYTHING
THAT WE USED TO RUN OUR
BUSINESS, WE SEE AT LEAST A 35%
INCREASE.
>> HE RUNS GALVESTON SHOULD
COMPANY AND HE SAYS PASSING
THOSE PRICES ONTO THE CONSUMER
IS NOT A RELIABLE OPTION.
>> IS A CONSUMER, SOMEHOW WE
WILL STOP BUYING IT.
IT TURNS INTO A RIPPLE EFFECT
WHERE THE PLANTS HAVE THE LAY
OFF EMPLOYEES --
>> Tucker: THE OCEANS
THEMSELVES ARE BEING DEPLETED OF
FISH, ENTIRE SPECIES BY THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT.
YOU HEAR A LOT ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT AND SAVING THE
PLANET, BY WHICH THEY MEAN,
DON'T DRIVE AN SUV.
BUT THE ACTUAL PLANET, ITS
ACTUAL RESOURCES, OUR OCEANS,
THE MOST IMPORTANT RESOURCE OF
THE PLANET HAS.
IT IS ABOUT THE OCEANS.
AND INCREASINGLY THEY ARE
POLLUTED AND BEREFT.
AND CHINA IS DOING THAT.
NO ONE IS SAYING A WORD ABOUT
IT.
SO INSTEAD OF ADDRESSING ANY OF
THESE PROBLEMS COME OUR LEADERS
ARE RESPONDING IN THE ONE WAY
THEY KNOW HOW.
AND IN THE PROCESS, WE ARE
DESPERATELY NEEDED TO STAY
SOLID.
GAVIN NEWSOM FOR EXAMPLE JUST
ANNOUNCED HE'S ABOUT TO GIVE HIS
RESIDENCE ANOTHER FREE
CREDIT CARD.
>> TODAY WERE ANNOUNCING THAT
$9 BILLION TAX REFUND TO TENS OF
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS.
$400 FOR EACH REGISTERED VEHICLE
DOTTED INDIVIDUAL OWNS.
UP TO TWO VEHICLES.
THAT DIRECT RELIEF WILL NOT
ADDRESS THE ISSUE THAT WE ALL
ARE STRUGGLING TO ADDRESS, AND
THAT IS THE ISSUE OF GAS PRICES.
>> SO IF THE HANDS AND FEET HERE
AND THE TEETH DISTRACTED YOU AND
YOU DIDN'T ACTUALLY HEAR THAT
ANYTHING THAT GAVIN NEWSOM SAID,
YOU CAN SAY THAT GAS PRICES ARE
REALLY HIGH SO WE ARE GOING TO
GIVE YOU A TAX REFUND, WHETHER
YOU PAY TAXES, IT'S WELFARE.
I'M NOT IS GOING TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM.
WHAT HE DOESN'T SAY IS THAT THEY
HAVE THE HIGHEST GAS PRICES IN
AMERICA, THE HIGHEST GAS TAXES
IN AMERICA.
$7 A GALLON IN LOS ANGELES, $7.
HE DID THAT.
BUT INSTEAD OF FIXING IT, HE'S
MAKING YOU MORE DEPENDENT.
THIS IS A TREND.
FOR THE SECOND TIME IN TWO
YEARS, POLITICIANS ARE SENDING
OUT WAY WELFARE CHECKS FOR
ECONOMIC CRISES THAT THEY
CAUSED.
SO IF YOU WANTED TO INCREASE
INFLATION, IF YOU WANTED TO MAKE
THE POPULATION WEAK AND
DEPENDENT UPO